>> So, Michael, I know we said that was the
last quiz but I think we should do one more
quiz. So the quiz is going to be on convex polygons.
And X is going to be an R squared. And
the hypothesis is going to be points inside some convex holygo-,
polygon. And, and inside means the same thing as we
meant with circles. So, if you're on the polygon or
on the perimeter of the polygon, then you're inside the polygon
for the purpose of this discussion. So, here's my question
to you Michael. What is the VC dimension of convex polygons?
>> Well, if I had to.
>> Ask someone else, you would say it was a quiz and you'd let them do it.
>> Is this a quiz? Oh, it's a quiz for me.
>> Well, I dunno, do you want to let the students get a, get a try?
>> Well, yeah, and then we can answer it by simply
going to the quiz if we actually go to the quiz [LAUGH].
>> [LAUGH] Okay, so let's go to a quiz. Go.